captivating new characters another
awesome mixtape and a generous helping
of heart are just some of the things
waiting for you in the bundle of son
misses guardians of the galaxy vol 2
yippee-ki-yay movie lovers it's Jan here
and just before I kick off my review
popper I want to let you know I'm
running a guardian to the galaxy vol 2
giveaway on all my new guardians 2
videos for a chance to win make sure
you're subscribed and leave a comment
about the movie on this video and I'll
have full details of the prizes at the
end of my review okay as I mentioned
before as well as our team of returning
heroes we also get a bunch of new
characters and actors who I really
enjoyed seeing in the movie as the
insect-like alien mantis Tom Clemente F
is a simply perfect addition to this
universe and gives a charmingly subtle
performance that really highlights our
characters innocence good nature and
humor and have scenes with Drax in
particular or an utter joy elizabeth
debicki you you'll have seen in The Man
From UNCLE and alongside Tom Hiddleston
and the TV series and night manager
gives us superbly stately and
condescending turn which fits her
character wonderfully as she plays Aisha
the High Priestess of the episode
arrogant alien race the sovereign and
Kurt Russell is just fantastic as ego in
all his forms managing to make this
crazy character believable and also
establishing a great on-screen rapport
with Chris Pratt star-lord
just like the first film there's plenty
of irreverent humor and volume to a lot
of which lands very well and there's a
good chunk of fun and thrilling action
too however this time there's also more
emotional weight given to the Guardian
story with an emphasis placed on family
whether that's the family you were born
into or the people you meet along the
way and having got to know his main cast
and characters well over the course of
filming the first movie it feels like
writer director James Gunn has really
honed this script so it pretty much
plays to each actors particular
strengths the fact that Drax has a lover
the literal as well as about as much
tact as a ton of bricks means that dave
bautista gets a mass of marvelously
funny lines which he nails thanks to his
great comic timing and delightfully
deadpan delivery and then there's that
hilariously hearty laugh Bautista does
as Drax which never fails to put a smile
on my face and you'll hear plenty of it
throughout the film as Peter quill aka
star-lord Chris Pratt showcases a range
of humor action and more heartfelt
dramatic moments while Zoe Saldana and
Karen Gillan get some cool
action and the chance to peel back the
layers of Gomorrah and nebulous
backstories and Michael Rooker certainly
makes the most of the increased screen
time yondu gets this time around adding
extra depth and his character as the
baby grew he's a mix of ultra cute
adorableness and a seething stack of
rage and the VFX guys are done a superb
job injecting this tiny tree creature
with a real sense of soul and
personality I also really like Bradley
Cooper's Rockets who gets a nice
emotional arc this time - yes there were
odd moments of his humor that didn't
work for me but he does still get lots
of great moments and I love Rockets in
all his fast-talking sass-mouth glory as
was the case with the first movie the
soundtrack for volume 2 with a gorgeous
mix I'm looking forward to listening to
again and again and as far as the movies
concerned
each track gels beautifully with the
scene at then taking the on-screen
visuals to another level speaking of
taking visuals to new heights
the production design for this movie is
out of this world from the sovereigns
planet which is all art deco-style
lavishness - egos home which perfectly
fits whose character is the work of the
movies art design and VFX teams really
shines and as you'd expect from a movie
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe there
are post-credit scenes 5 to be precise
so it's definitely worth sticking around
until the very end of the film plus
there are also plenty of Easter eggs and
references in the movie - and I'll be
making videos about those various
post-credit scenes and the significance
in the MCU as well as the movies Easter
eggs very shortly to sum up
guardians of the galaxy volume 2 is
entertainment of cosmic proportions or
to put it another way it was a pleasure
to watch writer director James Gunn
blend plentiful last with an emotional
kick in the gut and a galaxy of
scene-stealing performances from cast
old and new and I cannot wait to see
what Gunn has up his sleeve for volume 3
but in the meantime I'm looking forward
to watching volume 2 again now what are
you looking forward to about guardians
of the galaxy vol 2 and who are your
favorite characters in the Guardians
movies don't forget to comment and
subscribe for a chance to win one of
several guardians prizes I've got two
awesome hardback books from DK guardians
of the galaxy the ultimate guides the
cosmic outlaws which takes an in-depth
look at iconic characters issues and
storylines from the comics and I've also
got a selection of three very cool
Guardians Funko pop vinyl figures the
giveaway will run for two
three weeks on all my Guardians volume
two videos and I'll announce the winners
on a new video after that so make sure
you hit the bell to turn on
notifications so you stay up to date
with all my new videos and if you
enjoyed this video do hit that thumbs up
button and check out more of my
guardians of the galaxy vol 2 and Marvel
videos right here thanks for watching
and see you next time you became movie
lovers